[Music]
I wanted to start by thanking Adam for
inviting me to speak with you today it's
the real privilege I'm very excited to
be here I'm not so excited that I
dressed up or wear a Halloween costume I
did make a spooky version of my title
slide to start things off um and I
wanted to start by asking a few
questions from the audience so who who
here today is on a team that has data
scientists on it okay most people that's
great and for those of you who raised
your hands how many of you did your team
hire a data scientist in the in the last
year okay good good number how many of
you tried to hire a data scientist in
last year and had some struggles with it
still still lots of hands and how many
of you work on teams where you're
planning to hire data scientists in the
next year a lot more hands okay so
that's great
I glad to see all of that excitement and
you're in good company so it's not
surprising to me to see so many of you
working on teams where you're at it
you've actively been adding or looking
to add more data scientists to your
organizations this is a this is an old
oldie but a goodie this is an article
from 2012 from the Harvard Business
Review describing this what they were
just the authors were describing as an
emerging role was becoming increasingly
in high demand and one of the actually
so maybe I did maybe there is a
Halloween costume idea in here for
anyone who watched it if you want a
dresses like a sexy data scientist circa
2012 but hyperbole aside I think one of
the main points that this article is
making and many other people have made
and I'm certainly not the first person
to say this is that data scientists are
both difficult and expensive to hire and
I don't think they mean the data
scientists are difficult they are
difficult to hire and expensive to hire
it's also hiring data scientist is also
a really important task
probably it's important to all of you
who raised your hands you are all on
teams that are trying to hire them we
spend a lot of time in our modern life
at work with our colleagues who we
decide to add to our teams and work
closely with these are important
impactful decisions 2012 is an important
year for another reason it's the year
that insight was founded so I work at
insight the concept of insight in 2012
when it was founded as it is still today
was to bring together a group of
talented and sharp PhDs who are
individually each of them about 90% of
the way towards having all of the skills
and experience necessary to jump into
data science roles but they're lacking
some key pieces and so then by working
with them over the course of about a
month month and a half we could get them
a hundred percent of the way to to where
they need to be in the first year
insight worked with about 30 fellows
people in that first year went to places
like Facebook LinkedIn Twitter YouTube
Yammer and so there was a lot of early
signal that the insight was onto
something and since that time we now
work with an average of 20 to 30 people
every single session that we run and so
we're running about 10 to 12 different
sessions depending of different
iterations of different programs in
different locations and we do each of
those programs once we've got it sort of
fully scaled up roughly three times a
year
and so in 2017 alone we actually worked
with close to 500 500 fellows so I the
talk is not about how to come and be
part of insight but I did want to take a
minute to to remind everybody I checked
this morning as far as I can tell we are
still accepting late applications for
our first sessions that we'll be
starting up in 2018
they'll be happening in a variety of
cities in a variety of programs you can
go to the website to check out where
each of those programs will be half
in the new year I think that's all I
wanted to say there okay so pulling back
a bit then to talk about what insight is
and and where our experience then comes
from in recruiting and hiring data
scientists so insight is an education
startup that helps scientists and
engineers start new careers in data we
do this by running free programs these
programs are seven weeks long they're
completely free to the participants and
there are full-time fellowship programs
the free the freeness of it is important
for making sure that there are no
barriers to access to the program so we
get really great people apply and they
can all come in cite the program's
themselves have a very strong emphasis
on social learning so I often get asked
what is insights curriculum and if if
insight does have an official curriculum
it's certainly not a list of machine
learning algorithms or statistical
methods a lot of it is more focused on
how to how to know what you know how to
know what you don't know how to how to
figure out how to get from not knowing
something to to knowing something we
were very excited for people to bring
the talents that they already have and
may and apply them in the real world and
apply them in a business context so if
we were to try to kind of fix a specific
curriculum around what is the work of a
data scientist not only would that
quickly become stale and out-of-date but
anytime someone is confronted with a
problem or a scenario or severe question
but they don't know how to answer we
haven't really equipped them with the
tools to be able to get to an answer
yeah so another way that we make sure
that the what the fellows are actually
working on and learning is by placing of
putting a lot of sort of work around
learning from one's peers and industry
mentors so the alumni of our programs
come back and spend a lot of time with
the fellows mentoring them in specific
specific areas we have a lot of friends
many of whom are in the audience today
who also come back and give their time
as people out there in industry who are
working as data scientist working as
data engineers who come back and speak
directly to our fellows about if you're
going to build this here's how I would
suggest you do it if you're going to
analyze things in this way here are some
caveats or things to be aware of
ultimately the goal is for everybody to
start their supposed new careers and so
we do also have a component of training
around how to how to be successful in an
interview context so there's some
training around professional skills as
well as just giving the fellows a bit
more of a sense of what to expect in
that interview process the interview
process in an industry is wildly
different from any of the steps that
they've taken thus far in their academic
to move ahead in their academic careers
so that that's really important for them
so then to step back and just give you a
little bit more even sort of not talk so
much about the program itself but then
if you think about like what insight is
doing more broadly speaking it's
hopefully will resonate with a lot of
you who have been building building data
teams so we start by recruiting
identifying and then recruiting
potential data scientists that we want
to bring onto our team and for us what
that looks like is since our founding in
2012 I went back and looked at some of
these numbers there's 20,000
applications in our spreadsheets and as
a team collectively we've we've
conducted thousands of interviews with
candidates the next step then is to
onboard those individuals and train them
up as a team and then again to use
language that we don't really use in the
programs but that might look a little
more familiar to you every new member of
the team produces a functioning
prototype
of a data product within their first 20
days of being a member of that team
since since 2012 we earlier in the
summer we hit a new milestone which was
that there's now a thousand alumni who
our programs who are working in industry
they're working in a big cross-section
of teams and so that releasing them back
into the wild
they're they're now at a wide wide range
of companies across a bunch of cities
and and as I mentioned we'd then repeat
this over and over again and so that
what's nice about the repetition for us
is that we're able to iterate quickly on
processes like changes that we want to
make to our admissions process or any
sort of step along this way that we feel
didn't quite didn't quite hang together
didn't quite work as well didn't give us
the signal that we were looking for we
were able to make changes and deploy
those across all our programs so I
thought I would try to hit on four areas
to sort of share some some of my my
experiences our experiences that insight
I'm hoping to kind of move through this
material relatively quickly and then
leave plenty of time for questions but
I'll also be doing office hours after
after the lunch break so starting off
with finding people my bed my biggest
piece of advice is to start by doing
things that don't scale very well most
of you are on teams that are not going
to be hiring a hundred data scientists
in the next year so you can afford to do
things that don't scale when it comes to
hiring when it comes to people for us
what that looks like
although we do try to scale some of
these things the first piece of this of
my advice is to try it as much as
possible to talk to people directly so
it insight what that looks like is a lot
of university outreach and mailings that
go out to a network of department
administrators career counselors at
universities and and various other sort
of like contacts that we have in that
community the university outreach though
a lot of it is in-person visits and
those visits instead of coming to a
place like Columbia and which I've done
number of times to give talks my talks
are not really about insight I have a
lot of stuff to say about it's like in
the talks but the point of the talk is
not this is what insight is and how
awesome it is and you should you have to
come to insite if you want a career in
data the talks are generally
what even look what what does the career
and data even look like for somebody
coming from a quantitative research
background what are the what is the
landscape of opportunity look like
because that's one of the key questions
that most academics want to know more
about is what else out there can I even
do there they're working and living and
I say this from firsthand experience I
was myself you know in this pretty tight
bubble which I was very happy happily
ensconced in that bubble and so when I
started talking to my PhD advisor and
other people in my department about what
I thought I wanted to do after my
postdoc I got a lot of encouragement but
not a lot of good concrete advice and so
it's our hope that in our university
outreach that we actually go and give
some good concrete advice to people so
providing people with actual content
that's that's useful we do that through
the university outreach we also do a lot
of it on our blog and this is a way that
we can also help shape the signal that
candidates are giving us in our
admissions process and so you can think
about this as well in your own
recruiting recruiting efforts think
about the things you want people to know
about you and lean into subjects and try
to highlight them as much as possible so
on our blog we actually written a number
of posts about how to prepare for coming
to the program or how to prepare for
careers or prepare for career
transitions career transitions are hard
and scary and they're deeply stressful
and we want people to come into that
experience knowing what some of the
scarier or harder parts of it are and
equipped to handle it there's like a we
were hiring for a position at insite
this is not a related to fellows but we
were hiring for a position and we wrote
a job description for it it was a it was
a new role and we brought their job
description and I was really nervous
about getting qualified candidates and
so I looked at a lot of other job
descriptions for similar kinds of
positions and I was like okay I'm gonna
you know I'm gonna borrow a lot of this
language and this sounds really good and
I'm gonna use this and I wrote the most
boring generic job description but I
could probably have come up with and we
posted it and we got a lot of Canada
who applied really quickly some of whom
had like lots of very relevant great
experience but when we started doing
phone screens with them or initial calls
or even just looking at the cover
letters that people were submitting I
was really shocked because I thought I
would see a lot of people saying I'm
really excited to work at startup and
really excited to work in the education
space I'm really excited about like this
overlap between education and technology
and data and I got none of that and I
realized when I went back and looked at
the job description
that we hadn't said anything about our
team or like the size of our team or the
sort of culture of what it's like to
work it insight or what are some of our
goals and missions as an organization
and those things might seem like very
transparent to the outside world when
they're very clear to you because you
live and breathe your own life in your
own culture but they're not that clear
to people outside of your organization
and you have to be explicit about them
if you want them to signal that stuff to
you if you write a generic Job
Description people are gonna be like
cool sounds like a generic job I'm
qualified for it I will apply if you
write something that sounds a bit weird
or sounds a little bit out there it's
true that you might turn off some
candidates who are like I don't quite
get this but probably those are
candidates that you're not interested in
in meeting okay so moving along then
another another really good strategy
that we've had a lot of success with is
leveraging your existing network so it
insight what that looks like for us is
we we we look at alumni recommendations
very carefully our educational program
with its emphasis on social learning
it's pretty unique it's not for everyone
and so when an alum from our program
says to me oh hey I know this person I
think they'd be really good they're
doing that with a sort of hindsight of
experience of knowing how stressful or
how difficult the program was at times
and so so that oh that recommendation
means a lot the problem with all of the
things that I've just said is that
you're gonna have gaps in your network
and when you talk to people or when you
describe your data science we're always
like a ninja or something like you're
going to just like when you start using
coded language just talk to some people
out there
and not others you're gonna create gaps
in that in that Network and so you have
to actually do a lot of work to cover
those gaps we do this in a lot of
different ways an example though is
collaboration with women who code an
organization and that we've partnered
with to to provide some additional
scholarship support through people who
can who apply to insite through
connecting with them and then it helps
us reach out does do outreach in their
network so so figure out what gaps you
have that takes work work work even
harder to address them this is not
something that's gonna it's not
something that's gonna be easy it takes
takes actual work to do so don't be lazy
about it I guess ok so there's other
thing about finding people so know who
you're looking for and know who you
aren't seeing this is a little bit
related to these gaps and so I just
wanted to show some some data from our
our program so DJ Patil who's now the
former chief data scientist for the
United States but one time was quoted as
saying that the best data scientists
tend to be hard scientists rather than
computer science majors I feel left out
of this a little bit as a ecologist and
evolutionary biologist it's a pretty
hard science but depends on who you ask
what DJ I think was driving at and what
a lot of people have interpreted this to
mean is physics and so what I'm showing
here without any numbers are the Eric
fields of study of all of the past
candidates to the insights ever gotten
I'm just showing like the top 10 or 11
here so we so so physicists listened and
they have been applying to our program
in droves for many years we also have a
little strong representation from from
neuroscience from from biological fields
one of the big gaps here though is
there's a lot of quantitative fields
that aren't represented in this list and
and who clock in at very very tiny
percentages of our total applicant pool
but who we're still really excited to
see
to see show up and so whether it's
specifically going and doing
informational sessions or giving talks
to departments and in fields such as
these or keeping an eye out for those
applications when they come in it's been
very exciting to us over time insight
was founded by a physicist and so
another reason why are in our early
network is comprised largely a physicist
a true physicist is is because of that
and so again working to know what your
network looks like and push against it
but so folks who are coming from social
science backgrounds or or other fields
where the work itself is highly
quantitative or can be and then going
and finding those people in those areas
will bring a lot of not just diversity
of background but diversity of thought
and approaches and methods and things
like that and there's a ton that people
can learn from one another the other the
other thing that is always really
exciting to me when I see people coming
from these backgrounds is these are all
fields that are deeply human and for
many people working in data science a
lot of the questions that we're trying
to kind of use data as a proxy for is
some human decision-making and so so
these are fields where things like
selection bias and how surveys are
conducted is a big part of the work that
they do it was not a part of the work
that I was doing when I was scooping
tiny organisms out of lakes in Michigan
they were coming and getting in my
sample bucket whether they liked it or
not but these are fields where you have
to think a lot more carefully about
those types of biases I threw this in
here mainly because it's one of like I
have heard many things over the my three
years insight that are terrible but come
from people who are trying to grow their
teams one of the one of my biggest pet
peeves of all time is to hear that we
only recruit from from top schools um
for me this just signals that that
you're being incredibly lazy and you're
not even really willing to read
someone's entire resume let alone look
at their the full extent of their
background and so these kinds of
heuristics of like well I'm looking for
like a particle physicist who has this
may
years and like name checks these
technologies in their resume and I'm
done
might be a good way to sort of whittle
down the thousands and thousands of
applicants that you're getting to a
smaller narrower pool but it's probably
not a great way to design your your
search okay um again and then this is
still part of finding people going out
there and this is the longest part of
this so I didn't cite we're really lucky
because we're in the position of being
able to accommodate a really large group
of people every time we learn a session
not everybody who comes to our program
needs to be super excited about doing
client facing work if that's part of
what your team does or has to be able to
code in Scala or needs to be deeply
familiar with causal inference it's good
for the group if several or many people
in the group have those skills but not
everyone in the group needs to have them
for the for the session to be successful
you might be in a different position
where you have a single slot and you
need that person to check a lot of boxes
but if if you can approach the how
you're building your teams and how
you're thinking about them as a
composite of many skills in many areas
and people are able to cover the gaps of
others I think that'll that'll help you
so these are just sort of reiterating
some of the some of the points that I've
made in the last couple of slides
writing a very generic Job Description
will tell will get you a generic pool of
candidates so okay so then moving on
from how do you find people to then
thinking about interviews and so here
I'm not going to talk so much about
insights own interview process again
because it's an educational program it's
a it's a different what we're looking
for is different in certain ways I
wanted to sort of share some
observations about the sort of process
that teams generally use in industry to
to hire data scientists and so like many
other roles whether they're technical or
not they start with an initial call and
this might be with somebody from an HR
department who has your resume
in front of them it might be it might be
any any member of the team these initial
conversations fellows often describe
them to us in these surveys that we do
which is where the sort of data for this
comes from they they'd often described
them as behavioral but really when you
look into what are the content of the
questions that are often asked in these
kinds of interviews a lot of it has to
do with scheduling a lot of it has to do
with the team communicating directly the
person here's what the job actually is
here's who the manager would be here's
the team that's actually hiring things
like that so it's more around
communicating to the to the candidates
then and and clarifying of details and
things like that
following that candidates are put
through a variety of technical phone
screens but the icon I chose to use here
is a laptop because increasingly these
involve a shared live coding environment
like coder pet or some other tool where
someone is asking a candidate to walk
through some type of problem that
involves a live coding and so that's
that's for that data challenges where a
candidate is given a piece of work or a
question or a set of data and sent away
with it to work on it for some number of
hours are an increasingly popular tool I
was surprised actually I thought the
numbers would be higher I went in and
looked at the number of times not just
the number of individual data challenges
that have been handed out to fellows but
the number of teams within amongst all
the teams that we work with number of
teams that actually used data challenges
and it's actually only about 20% or 25%
of the companies that we work with the
numbers are slightly lower here in New
York it's about 20% of teams that
insight works with in California Bay
Area it's closer to 30% I suspect that
some of that has to do with when
companies do decide to work with us that
might be a state stage that they're
often choosing to to skip over but but I
also think that data challenges are
great but they also are very
consuming so they're time consuming for
candidates and I would encourage any of
you who are using data challenges as a
way to weed out candidates or vet them
or rank them or score them to make sure
that you've actually taken the time to
work through your own challenge or give
it to a pool of people where you can get
honest feedback from them on how long it
actually took them to do the work that
they've submitted to you candidates
underestimate the amount of time they
spend on these that's that's you're
never gonna get around that and so it's
it's possible that teams are you know at
least being smart and let's not use this
all the time if we don't have to because
it's they do involve a lot of work and
then one thing though that I have seen a
more and more is instead of submitting
whether it's like a you know a notebook
or some piece of code to run or here's a
written report but actually having
candidates come in and deliver a 30 to
40 minute presentation of walking them
through here's here's what you asked me
to do and here's how I went about doing
that for me that what's nice about that
is it actually gets back to what data
challenges are designed to do which is
put the felt put the I keep saying
fellas for the candidates in a scenario
that really mimics what it might
actually be like to work with the team
so that's the almost all interview
processes culminate and one or new one
or more on-site interviews with
candidates these on-site interviews
often have an enormous behavioral
component to them
candidates are always most freaked out
by having to get up at the white board
and reverse strings but actually talking
to people about why they want to be at
that company why they want to join that
team in particular what excites them
about the work that the teams are doing
those are huge huge pieces of it so
the the nice thing about so breaking it
up into these these four categories is a
nice way to conceptualize this and you
know it might be nice if if this was
sort of the the process for how things
worked everywhere and uniformly across
the board it looks a little bit more
like this in reality this is actually
totally fine though it's okay to move
Canon I mean these categories are kind
of they're not that meaningful in and of
themselves and candidates are fine with
multiple steps as part of an interview
process I've never heard someone really
complain about the number of steps being
too big unless they felt at any one
stage like their time was really being
wasted like if they start talking to
some some people about a role they move
through the technical screens get to the
on-site only to realize that they're
actually being considered for a
different job than the one that they
initially had talked about with the
recruiter the huge red flag for them
because it means that you guys aren't
like you're not organized and and and
that their time is being wasted and and
on both sides that's a that's a real
concern so don't give data challenges
without actually testing how long they
take to do it don't say that you're
gonna call them on Thursday if you're
not actually gonna call them on Thursday
a lot of these you know a lot of my
advice here is really treat them the
same way that you would want to be
treated if you were going going through
the process I think something that comes
up a lot with academic candidates in
particular is if you can avoid putting
them in any situations that feel like an
examination you will get stronger signal
from them about how they're more likely
to behave on your team they have a lot
of Pavlovian responses to things that
are called like take homes or you know
tat like they're just they retreat back
to today to learn behaviors from their
academic experience that can put them
into a really confrontational mode that
can put them into a sort of like oh I
just have to spit out the right answer
and that's all they're looking for kind
of behavior so so as much as possible
try to engage those candidates in a more
conversational way and there's there's
different ways that you can signal that
to them even just by explicitly saying
this whiteboard thing that we're going
to
it's not a test I'm not here to sort of
you know put you on the spot and and
demand like instant recall of obscure
facts and formulas I really just want to
talk to you about a problem and and see
how we would work through it together if
we were to be on the same team and even
that can defuse the situation and put
them much more into a headspace where
you're more likely to actually then have
a good experience whether or not the
interview was successful or not you're
at least more likely they get better
signal something I ain't can encounter
oh yeah I had another like so maybe
sometimes you go from this right to that
sighs I have that's fine too okay so um
last thing I wanted to say about inter
it's not really related to interviews
although salaries and salary
expectations come up a lot in interviews
I wanted to put this graph up and ask
you what do you think it's a graph of
salaries for men and women how many
people most people that's what yeah so
it's not I tricked you sorry that trick
or treat so so this is actually salaries
comparing fellows who have left insight
first year base salary for cities of New
York and the Bay Area so there's a bit
of a bump we should all leave New York
and move to San Francisco if we want to
raise our base salaries starting data
scientists so I put this in here for
context because I'm delighted to show
you our actual lack of gender
differences in first-year base salaries
for fellows leaving insight and this is
so this this is not what you see when
you go out and look at like the O'Reilly
surveys or other other data that's out
there I think what this is signalling is
a few things one of them is that there
are practices in industry there are
standards that are that exist out there
in the world there's there's like the
condition the general human condition
and then there's the things that we can
do to change that and one of them is
just by being a little bit
and you giving everybody a little bit
more access to information and education
so sharing information about what's
normal and what's expected and so some
of this has to do with people better
understanding their market value it has
to do with normalizing the idea of
negotiating a salary in the first place
there may also be some some bias and the
companies that are represented in this
data set because we've certainly stopped
working with teams who have been jerks
for various reasons so but anyway so
that's so that I just wanted to include
that in the interview product okay so
this what's next part you know this is
these next two parts are pretty fast so
after people become data scientists what
do we see and amongst all of those
thousand alumni what do what do they
become next what's their what is their
next job look like so I I ran through a
a pretty it's we don't have a ton of of
data here but I think these numbers are
there okay so so most of them are not
Muslim sorry about thirty percent of
them their second role in in this new
career is also as a data scientist
sometimes that's because they've joined
a new team or move to a new company but
sometimes it's just more specialized so
machine learning data scientist or
product analytics data scientist or
something like that 15 percent of them
tend to sort of pivot or shift a little
bit more towards software engineering or
data engineering or machine learning
engineer positions another 30 a little
more than 30 percent like within a year
maybe to rapidly progressed a senior
staff data scientist lead data scientist
positions only about 5% of all the
alumni who have gone on to data science
roles and then gone on to something else
only about 5% have stepped into
managerial positions I went in and
pulled out anybody that was a product
manager because I really just wanted to
identify people who were managing teams
so that number is is small there weren't
that many product manager
either and that that number is small
that number to me is whirring one of the
biggest trends that people keep talking
to me about is the lack of data science
managers it's something that we think a
lot about an insight come talk to me at
office hours if you want to chat about
it another 17% are all in this sort of
miscellaneous bucket these are people
who who had new titles I think some of
them in lieu of and then others in
addition to continuing to work as data
scientists so things like consultants
founders CEOs advisors to startups or to
or in the funding space okay
so some of the takeaways that I hope to
have imparted to all of you this morning
um so finding people finding people in
general it's pretty easy you can put up
a job posting and watch watch things
pile in on you from indeed finding the
right people for your role that you have
open now will actual take some real work
and so so don't think that just by
hanging out a shingle you're gonna find
the best people that you can possibly
find and digging in at the top of your
funnel is probably the place that will
have the not just the highest impact but
will make every future subsequent step
that much better for you the the more
information that candidates have them
about the role and the team the more
likely it is that you'll get the the
best people for the role actually go on
it who actually wanted to come and talk
to you so interviews can vary wildly do
what you like you know I'm not here to
tell you how to run your interview
process but the process itself shouldn't
be opaque people should understand who
they're meeting with what the sort of
expectations are in terms of timeline
how long the process will take you know
if if you need to pause a search for
like you say you start a search and
you're gonna do a bit and then all of a
sudden you're doing a big reorg don't
just leave those candidates in limbo
waiting for you to get back to them tell
them hey we're we're we're undergoing
some
some reorganization we're not sure if
the role or when the role might might
actually fit in the new system but we
we're not done here we'll come back to
people will respond much better than
that then you know two months of radio
silence and yes you might scare off some
people who are like you seem
disorganized if you're if you're having
to do this but that's fine because if
you actually are an organization that
has to reword you don't want people that
are scared by that to be on your on your
team
the career path for data scientists is
still really wide open it's not a path
until a bunch of other people have gone
down it before so stay tuned for that
and then finally I wish you the best of
luck this is a challenging space to be
working in I really enjoy it it's a
tremendous pleasure to get to work with
all of these super talented people every
day but it's it is but it is hard thanks
all of you for listening as a reminder
we are still accepting late applications
and then these are some two ways to to
find me in addition the office hours
this afternoon
[Applause]
any questions
hi so one of the big things that we do
that I don't know if it's a good idea or
not but in the Job Description
we try to make it cool but one of the
things that we do is we say hey here's
like a fun problem you know solve it and
send it back with the resume to have a
deal and we know that it's not too
difficult of a problem and the only
concern that I personally have about
that is like attrition rate because I
know that if I'm applying for a job and
they're gonna make me solve a problem
and it's gonna take me an hour I'm
probably gonna just apply for somewhere
else unless it's like Google or Facebook
or somebody really fancy so like do you
have any way of quantifying attrition
rate because maybe I'm the one that's
just an [ __ ] or maybe it's a lot of
people and that's why we're severely
limiting our applications for good
people yeah so that comes up for us and
not so much in our data science
application although we can look at some
web metrics and look at like who's
actually going to the page and then who
actually hits apply and fills it out and
stuff like that but for our data
engineering program candidates after
they apply are sent a coding challenge
for the engineering program and we do
hope we do have some statistics on like
how many people actually complete it and
so I I don't I haven't looked at those
numbers I can't tell you them off the
top of my head but it but it's a it's a
concern that I think you want to weigh
against how like how much do you care
about losing people that aren't aren't
willing to spend that much that that
amount of time or invest that even if
you're not Spotify or Google or whoever
you know like if you if you if you're
still excited to apply and go through
that step I think what you want to be
careful about is making sure that that
bar is not so high that somebody who
just you know already has a job or has
you know is busy like this idea of like
come work for us for free for a while
and then like then we'll think about it
you know they like you want to make sure
that you're not just sort of only people
who can afford to sync the time and are
applying so keeping that bar relatively
easy and easy enough threshold but a
threshold nonetheless to just sort of
weed out the people who are sending
their resume
literally everywhere they can I think
it's probably a good idea I don't know
where the microphone is that Nick
I'm wonder if you have any feedback from
your candidates on honey
how many of them effectively are doing
more data engineering than data science
and because there isn't enough data
engineering there and they're
effectively their company's first data
engineer all of a sudden yeah it's a
it's a good question I don't have
numbers on that except for the the
number who have actually shifted into a
more of an engineering title in their in
their roles which I do think isn't
interesting like because those are
people who have now who have worked as a
data scientist who are officially
shifting into a more of an engineering
right yeah and so that and that's where
it's hard just to go from job titles to
like what is someone actually doing in
their day-to-day and that's one of the
challenges in general of having a field
where there's really only like a half a
dozen different things that we call
ourselves and what a data scientist does
at a team like the New York Times or a
team like BuzzFeed's
oh those are those could be very
different things they could be very
similar things in one instance they
might end up doing a lot more
engineering work and others they might
end up doing a lot more client-facing
work and so those kinds of skills
surveys is something that we've thought
about doing but we haven't done quite so
much because this is the thing that
comes up a lot when you look at data
from LinkedIn I'm just like what titles
do people have that's sort of the level
that that I've been able to probe so far
just from looking at our alumni LinkedIn
pages but then actually digging in more
into like what are you actually doing in
your day today what skills are you using
every day and it depends a lot mostly on
the size and scale of the size and stage
of the team but yeah so on for I don't
I'm sorry I don't have a better answer
for you so I guess my question is um so
I find in my experience data scientists
kind of have like three major
responsibilities one being numbers the
second being engineering the third being
product and an ear example interview
process you kind of hit the the numbers
and like the analysis and the
engineering and the coding paired coding
exercise but do you have you seen any
examples of good interviews that touch
on the product aspect of data science so
when
you say product you wanted to say a
little more about product as in like
being able to translate a user's needs
into numbers and identify what is
actually the real kind of like how a UX
designer would identify what is the pain
that someone's feeling and a user
interface being able to translate what
is the pain that someone's feeling and
translating it into and this is specific
to certain types of products where
you're selling numbers as opposed to
analysing your users secretly yeah so we
do this in some of these post interview
surveys that that I was referencing
earlier we do ask the candidate we do
ask the fellows like in those broad
categories what kinds of questions came
up in the interview we're not interested
in becoming just like a we have no
interest in being a resource for what
questions did you get and like so for
people to share that information because
we don't think that that's a useful way
to run our organization but what was
surprising to us is once we started
actually looking at some of these
numbers felt like a lot of our interview
prep material is really focused
historically on preparing candidates for
some of the stuff that that they're
weakest in and so some of that is for
the data scientists it's things like
sort of a classic textbook like SIA some
fundamentals of CS or stats like just
probability distributions and things
like that and so we're really heavy on
like just make sure that you have those
basics so that you don't get caught off
guard and something that came up in
these in these surveys quite a bit was
just a number of open-ended questions
that teams are asking candidates and so
the number of interviews where you're
actually maybe maybe you are at a white
board maybe not but not because you're
writing pseudocode or actual code but
actually because you're mapping out like
how you might think about if you have
these users and then they have these
concerns and you're thinking about
opening a new store and your location or
those kinds of questions where you're
actually really just dissecting a
problem in conversation with someone
those are very very common I think one
thing that's interesting about those
things is I don't know that it's just
really about product necessarily I think
it can be about a lot of a lot of areas
in our interview process when we talk to
candidates and I happy to share this
with you we we look for four categories
and they're very similar to what you
were talking about so
looking for hands-on experience with
real data so we're suspicious when we
see only simulation work we want to see
some exposure to real data to have some
sense of like what you should and
shouldn't trust experience with
statistics experience in coding and then
communication skills and for us
communication skills is not just
eloquence or how articulate someone can
be and explaining their research or
talking about complicated topics but how
does like what's the sort of back and
forth of their communication do they
actually listen to the questions I'm
asking do they seem really annoyed when
I interrupt them to clarify a point or
are they actually like excited to to
clarify the point and not in a fake way
but but are they actually interested in
having a real communication with me or
are they just there to lay information
out to me and communicate at me as
opposed to with me that's something that
we've been modifying our own interview
process increasingly to like to try to
capture that signal a little bit more
it's kind of long answer sorry there's
one more at the back and I'm sorry it's
quite bright over here so I can't see if
there's hands coming up
Thanks so how do you balance you know
when you're trying to it like look at
your pool of data scientists when you
first put out an interview or a job
description how do you balance like you
know the ease of your alumni network
with like a diverse pool of candidates
because it's very easy for me to go find
another physicist you know like me or
someone who looks like me from my own
like alumni network or a professional
background so you mean how do we like
make sure we're connecting to groups of
like departments that we don't have
alumni from for example yeah I mean not
so much you guys but like as a hiring
manager and you're looking for
candidates you know like obviously I
will go and like look at my professional
network and my alumni network but those
people look very much like me right yeah
so but in the interests of like
diversity and you know any types of
diversity you want to talk about like
you're you're not gonna have that
diverse pool if you're looking at people
like yourself yeah I I think it comes
down to like how much you actually care
about or value that that diversity or
like what you're gonna be gaining from
having those those candidates in your
pipeline or ultimately joining your team
we care about it a lot and so we we put
we put a lot of work into it are we're
sort of like constantly thinking and
working on the way that we're conducting
the outreach that we do improvements
that we can make ways to widen that
funnel ways to partner with other
organizations and just trying to like do
all of the things that we like like I
said before like doing the things that
aren't scalable necessarily that we can
just try as many of them that we suspect
might work and then when we hit on
something really good try to recreate
that you know across other fields or
other areas so we yeah so we put a lot
of value on it so we're we're having
invested in that for other organizations
and other teams I think it depends you
know like hiring is one of the many
things that that people have to worry
about I think it's I think it's the most
important one but that's me
and so good you know it should be I
think a lot of time and energy but it
you're right that it does it comes at
the cost because it does take time and
and a lot of times you know you go and
talk to people and you know they might
not be interested that's okay
[Music]